everybody in
okay so uh welcome to the fourth lecture
in this series
this is a more or less a tribute to uh
one of my
fabulous former students jose de arnay
who proved the
crucial made the crucial contribution to
the proof that i'm going to describe
she's a french canadian woman and uh not
that fluent in english
so when she presented this result at
licks several years ago juan pratt
asked her a long and convoluted question
at the end that's hard to understand and
harder to answer so she just looked at
him and said i'm sorry i've used up all
my english words
so uh
so what i'd like to talk about today is
the logical characterization
of this uh by simulation so this is a
principle for reasoning about
the behavior of probabilistic systems
and by simulation is an equivalence
relation you can think of it
as being defined on processes but
perhaps
it's simpler to think of it as being
defined on the states of
a transition system that behave exactly
the same
in some observable sense so i have to
make these definitions all precise
and what was striking was the fact that
there is a nice modal logic which gives
you
a complete characterization of this
relation in the sense that
two states are exactly behaviorally
equivalent if they agree
on all the formulas of this modal logic
okay so
form uh theorems like this have been
known fan bentham
and then hennessey milner approved such
a theorem for label
transition systems these are well-known
results from the 70s
but the probabilistic analogs of this
emerged in the 80s
and then this result is for
probabilistic transition systems but
defined on continuous state spaces
of a certain kind where it was perhaps
unexpected
that still something as discrete as a
simple modal logic could still
characterize behavioral equivalence
so i'll give a brief summary of label
transition systems and then i'll move on
to labeled markov processes
by the simple device of replacing the
transition relation
with probabilistic relations that i
introduced yesterday
and then i will give some intuitions and
examples
but then i will have to make a
digression into the theory of polish and
analytic spaces
and then i'll get back to the proof and
then i'll say a bit about stimulation
which is of course
not the same as bisimulation but closely
related and for which there is also a
logical characterization but with an
unexpected twist
and finally i'll say some something at
the end
miraculously called concluding remarks
so the transition system
you have a set of states a set of labels
or actions and a transition relation
typically written with this arrow
and these transitions could be
indeterminate and again the
indeterminacy is not quantified in any
way so these are the standard
label transition systems i didn't know
this at the time but they were
introduced by my former masters
thesis supervisor robert keller anyway
so
these are label transition systems and
models of many kinds
of simple discrete dynamical systems
we will typically write the the
transition
label on top of the arrow rather than
like that as a triple
okay so just simple examples we might
have a four state system
you see the state s under an a
transition could go to one of two places
it's not determined
to which place it goes once it gets to
s2 it can do a b
transition and get to s3 and s1 it's
already dead
and here's another example you see it
could go to two different states under
different transitions
it so happens that the transitions out
of s0
are determinate in this case they need
not
uh b and for example when you get to s1
you have you see the indeterminacy in
the c labeled
transition okay so these are typical
examples of label transition systems
and one typically has some story about
vending machines to explain these things
to students
okay so by simulation so i just want to
say this quickly
because these are well-known things in
this
case so we will say two states are by
similar
if the transitions from one state
can always be matched by corresponding
transitions of the other so if s can do
an a transition
to s prime there's some state t prime
such that t
can match that and the resulting pair
are themselves by similar
and vice versa okay so i won't always
write both counterparts i might often
say just
and vice versa to indicate the symmetry
of the relationship all right so this
may
appear slightly circular but it isn't
and it can be made rigorous in various
ways so
here's one so we'll define a by
simulation relation so please take note
of the fact that i've now used the
indefinite article
a bisimulation relation to be an
equivalence relation on the states
such that if they are related by that
relation
and then one of them does an a
transition to a state s prime
then t can also do an a transition to a
corresponding state
with the s prime and the t prime related
and again vice versa
now there's nothing circular about this
you've given me a relation and you can
check whether or not it has this
property it might it might not
if it does then indeed we will call it a
by simulation relation
so it is just a condition on r and now
we will say
s and t are by similar if there is some
by simulation relation r
with that property so you can say by
simulation
is the largest possible by simulation
relation that one can find
and indeed there is a nice greatest
fixed point characterization of it
that you get by iterating an appropriate
functional on the lattice of
relations okay so this is the version
that is used most often
and the one that i will use in the
probabilistic setting
or at least i will the one i will base
the probabilistic
version on so labeled markov processes
are the labeled
are the probabilistic analogs of these
label transition systems
so again you have a set of labels
and transitions but now the final state
is actually governed by
a probability distribution it's not just
purely indeterminate
so it's quantified and i emphasize that
there is no
other indeterminacy so you will see a
number of different models
people talk about mixing probability and
non-determinism
perhaps saying once you execute a
certain action
then one of a set of probability
distributions is chosen
and then further the final state is
determined by that distribution so i'm
not doing that
everything all the indeterminacy is
quantified in this
traditional probabilistic fashion
okay so there is all the probabilistic
data is internal
okay so once an action is chosen then
there is some probability distribution
governing the final states
we are not attempting to say how those
actions are chosen we are not saying a
happens with probability half or
anything like that
we're just saying given an action here's
how it responds
to that action
and what is important is that we don't
actually observe
the state of the transition system at
all you don't get to see what state
you're in
you just get to see what actions you can
perform
so you can think of this as being
modeled by some kind of black box with
some buttons that you get to press
these buttons are the actions and
perhaps
the system will actually reject a
certain action so you press the button
and you will hear perhaps a satisfying
click and you know some transition has
happened
but you don't get to see where it's gone
all you get to see is that yes this
action was accepted
and if you do it enough you'll get to
perhaps associate
a transition probability with that
action okay
right and i should mention
uh it's not on the slides but i always
have sub probability distributions
because i always allow you to perhaps
have actions that are just not accepted
by the machine
as for example in our standard vending
machine examples if you press the button
to serve you coffee before you put in
the money it just won't respond
okay so so sub probabilities
uh govern the actions
so these kinds of things were studied by
several people
uh larsen and score prominent names in
this area
but the the new thing i and my
co-authors did was
to start studying this on continuous
state spaces
okay so right now i'm just using the
somewhat vague term continuum i will
give a more precise definition presently
okay so how do we define transitions on
top of these continuous state spaces
well this is what i talked about
yesterday
we use markov kernels and i try to argue
from the categorical viewpoint that
these are the correct
generalizations of the notion of
transition matrix or
or binary relation so markov kernel just
to remind you
is a two argument function it takes a
state
and a set if you fix the state and let
the set vary you get a sub probability
measure
if you fix the set and let the state
vary you get
a measurable function and so though
apparently asymmetric these are indeed
the probabilistic analogues of binary
relations
and they share much but not all of the
algebra of binary relations
and also they generalize the notion of
matrix and the composition law
generalizes the notion of matrix
multiplication so
one is used to using transition matrices
for markov chains and multiplying them
to describe
successive transitions so it's the exact
same thing happening here
in the same way so let me give a formal
definition of these things which i call
labeled markov processes
so we have a set because it's in general
a complicated space one has to pick out
a sigma algebra of measurable sets
there's a set of labels and for every
possible label there is a transition
probability function tau
which is satisfies the following
conditions
so first of all the set together with
its underlying sigma algebra is the
borel
algebra of an analytic space and
suddenly this thing has
popped out of nowhere so uh
yes i i'm i was as surprised as you are
when this entered the subject so let me
punt on that for the moment but
presently
i will you will see why i had to do that
so analytic spaces indeed are a
restriction that's not all
measurable spaces but they are extremely
common most of the things that
you see in science and engineering are
indeed polish spaces let alone analytic
and if you wake up one morning and you
find you're not in an analytic space i
would be worried
okay so this
is the transition function which is a
markov kernel and it has the type that
i've been talking about before as
as i said before it's a probability
measure in one argument and a measurable
function in the other
now probabilistic by simulation closely
mimics
what i did for ordinary bisimulation
this definition sometimes people think
theorems are hard but definitions are
even harder sometimes this took us a
long time to come up with
and it was shocking at the end that it
was so similar to the original
definition of pi simulation because we
went through a long detour with lots of
category theory
but i promised to spare you category
theory today
so this is the definition we finally
converged on so
sometimes we introduce an initial states
that's the little i there sometimes not
i'm not going to worry about it too much
so we will say an equivalence relation
r on a set s is a by simulation if
whenever you take a related pair
and then you look at r closed
so an r closed set simply says if a
point is in the set then anything
related to it by r
is also in the set if r is an
equivalence relation then this simply
means
some union of equivalence classes so if
you take an
r closed measurable set that was
practically the only thing we had to do
then you want the transition
probabilities of s to that set
and s prime to that set to match up okay
so you can't talk about point-to-point
transition probabilities
especially not in the in the case where
your underlying system might be
continuous
so we have to talk about transition
probabilities to measurable sets
and also because probabilistic by
simulation
is not just concerned with matching the
transitions but also with the transition
probabilities
you have to essentially think of them as
unions of equivalence classes
i go to sets that are already matched up
okay so that's the definition of
probabilistic by simulation
and we'll say two states are bisimilar
if they are related by some by
simulation relation
okay so that's again secretly you can
see that as the greatest fixed point
definition of some kind
is it obviously that in this context the
union of two by simulations
is a bicycle it's not obvious but it's
easy
okay because those obviously the
standard difference
right so as i said it's not obvious it's
easy easy means
yeah well usually easy things are true
so yes easy means i'm not going to show
you the proof but i'll show it to you
next week if you ask me again
okay now we come to the heart of the
matter
a logical characterization theorem for
these things
so i should say for the discrete case
people study discrete probabilistic
transition systems before
and they studied a number of equivalence
relations testing
similarity and by simulation
so i should be saying strong
probabilistic by simulation all the time
but let me drop all those adjectives
and what they showed was that there was
a logical characterization of by
simulation
however they had the following kinds of
restrictions
on the systems so first of all it had to
be finitely branching
but in fact stronger than that there had
to be a given
in advance a bound on the degree of
branching so not just finitely branching
but
some number had to be specified like 17
and then
you were not allowed branching more than
that uh
more stringent still was a requirement
that all the probabilities that appeared
in the description of the system had to
be integer multiples of some small
number
so that would be some fixed small number
epsilon and everything had to be
some multiple of that given small
positive number i'm not sure why i'm
saying small
didn't have to be that small but you
know what i mean some smallest
probability that was the only thing that
had
that was allowed to appear so there was
a very discreet character to the whole
thing
the logic itself had negation in it
or there were other variants it didn't
have full-blown negation but all of them
had some kind of negative
construct for example a formula that
said this system cannot do an a
action at this stage okay so
you will notice this logic which i still
haven't explained
has just the atom true
binary conjunction and this modal
operator which i will explain in a
minute
intuitively it means a system or a state
that can
that satisfies this formula can do with
probability strictly greater than q
it can do an a transition and wind up in
a state that satisfies phi
okay so it's the standard one step
modality that you would expect
for this kind of uh transition system
nothing negative so it's a purely so you
notice the must
which is the dual to the may operator is
not there
that has a hidden negation in it nothing
like
i cannot do an a is is there at all so
this was a purely positive logic
another famous uh josiahism the first
time she presented
this result people absolutely didn't
believe it
and they jumped up and said no no no
this can't be right
and again not being entirely fluent in
english
and not knowing how to be super polite
she said be quiet
at the end of my talk you will have no
more doubts so
so people were so shocked by this they
just stopped
asking questions so
yeah so these were the prices so
remember i said that for the discrete
case you had this strong finite
branching assumption
this is the continuous case finite
branching assumptions would be
completely silly to
impose in such a situation you're
thinking perhaps of something diffusing
across
the real line it's not even going to be
countably branching it could well be
some kind of uncountable branching
this is why in the beginning we were not
that
optimistic that there would even be a
logical characterization because we were
thinking we might
have some kind of ridiculous infinity
conjunction
but magically all these things turned
out to be unnecessary and it wasn't
the proof doesn't go by the usual
combinatorial arguments
which are extremely clever in the uh
existing work instead it used some
rather
unexpected machinery about
analytic spaces
so let me give a formal definition to
this i've told you the intuition
we'll say a state satisfies that if with
probability strictly more than q
by the way it doesn't matter that much
if you change it to greater than or
equal to you can prove the same theorem
it's just
easier in the one talk to do to stick to
an inconsistent
interpretation so strictly greater than
q with
a probability strictly greater than q
i can do an a action and wind up in a
state that satisfies phi
so a is an action q is a rational number
a rational number
between 0 and 1. why rational so that
i'm defining only countably many
formulas by this syntax
okay and formally i have to define it by
this hodgepodge of greek symbols
so you might say why didn't you just
define what it means for this to have
the set of states that satisfy phi
and then say the transition probability
into that is greater than q
it's because these transition
probabilities are only defined on
measurable sets
i don't a priori know that the set of
states satisfying phi is a measurable
set so i have to say it in this awkward
way
and then immediately prove a lemma
saying that those sets are measurable
okay which is a very easy lemma and i'm
going to skip it
so our basic result appeared in licks
and then
with the usual delay it appeared in a
journal
okay so why can't this possibly be
correct
well let's look at the non-deterministic
case
so here there are no probabilities it's
a completely
finitary indeterminate situation
and so we have these two systems that
we're comparing
s naught and t naught you see s naught
can have
a branching coming out of it on under an
a action
t naught does not and so
it's an easy exercise to show that if
you write down
a basic modal formula
there is no way you can distinguish
these two without using negation
you can use you can easily prove that by
induction on the structure of positive
formulas
by easily i mean i've even put it on
midterm exams and my students have been
able to do it
so it's it's a really easy proof and
this is why people immediately said
our result can't possibly be right
because this is a you can't do this
without negation there's a simple
negative
negated formula that distinguishes them
basically you have to be able to say
i can do an a action and go to somewhere
where t or b
is impossible which is not satisfied
there
but to say a b is impossible requires
some kind of negative construct
now if you add probabilities to the
transitions
so let's say this now happens with the
probability p
and that happens with probability q this
one happens with probability r remember
i said sub probability so this doesn't
have to be one nor does the sum of p
plus q have to be one it could be
something less than one
and these unlabeled ones i just mean
probability one in that case
so if it so happens that the sum
p plus q is different from r
either strictly less or strictly greater
well then there's always a rational
number in between them
and you can write a formula that will
readily distinguish them because they'll
have
different probabilities for responding
to an a
okay suppose p and q exactly equals
r and suppose
p is strictly greater than zero now if p
is in fact
zero then of course this is the same as
that
and they should indeed be bi-similar so
if they're
if you're really saying they're not
quite similar it's because p
plus q uh sorry because p is strictly
greater than
0. so if p plus q is exactly equal to r
and p is strictly greater than 0 then q
is strictly less than r
and so now i can use some formula i can
find some
rational number in between q and r
and distinguish them by seeing how they
respond to a b
okay so i have constructed positive
formulas in this case
by exploiting the probabilities of
course this is not a proof
sadly you cannot prove things by killing
the first counter example
so but it suggests that something more
uh tricky is happening than you might
otherwise think
okay so now let me begin the proof of
the logical characterization so first of
all
this pi simulation is a very strong
relation and not surprisingly it implies
logical equivalence it's an easy proof
by structural induction
on the formulas and if you want to see
it you should look at it some other time
it's very easy and it'll be on these
slides okay
for the reverse direction we were stuck
for a long time
and we had this idea that perhaps things
would be better behaved if we worked on
polish spaces
right now to remind you a topological
space is called separable
if it has a countable dense subset
and in the case of separable metric
spaces this is the same thing as saying
that it has a countable base of open
sets
now a polish space is the topological
space underlying
a complete separable metric space of
course you cannot just say a topological
space is complete that doesn't mean
anything
but it has a metric then you can talk
about it being complete but the point is
we don't actually care about the metric
we care about the underlying topology so
that's
a polish space and measure theory works
well on polish spaces
okay so still you might think why
did topology creep into this story
so as i said i think i said this before
measure theory works really nicely on
polish spaces
for example if you just look at this
obvious thing you take the borel sets of
x1 cross
x2 in the product sigma algebra and you
take the
product sigma algebra of the borel sets
of x1 and x2 they might or might not be
the same in fact
in general measure spaces but they'll
always coincide with polish spaces
i should also mention in passing the
monad i defined yesterday can be defined
on polish spaces
so this was not something in lovers
original notes but
this was worked out carefully by jerry
herself
analytic spaces where did these things
come from
so well there's this
famous book by um
is it le beg yes i think it was lebeg
who wrote this famous book on measure
theory on measure and integration
and he made this remark that if you take
a borrel subset of the plane
r2 and project it onto the x-axis then
clearly the
projection is borel
uh right so
a young student in russia suslin was
reading this book and he said gosh i
must be stupid i don't see why this is
true
and he struggled with it for a long time
and then he took it to his advisor luzon
and they struggled with it all day and
they couldn't do it either
and then susan went home and invented
analytic sets
which are a counter example to that
claim
so uh
analytic sets are basically things that
you get by looking at images of polish
spaces
under borel functions so in fact there
are
six equivalent definitions maybe i will
actually draw things on the board
so you can take two polish spaces
x and y you can look at a continuous
function
f and you can look at the image
of f of x the image of x under f
in y that set will be analytic so you
can take that as the definition
but then you can also notice that if i
change
f from being continuous to being
measurable
you don't actually enlarge the class of
analytic spaces so this is a bit of a
shock but it is true
it doesn't matter whether i say f is
continuous or f is analytic
okay it doesn't matter if i say i take
x or if i take a borel subset of x
i look at the continuous or measurable
image of a borel subset of x i get the
same class of analytic spaces so i've
just given you
four definitions of analyticity and then
it doesn't matter
if i take a generic polish space or a
very special one
namely n infinity so
the important point about analytic
spaces is that they are
nice and stable under things you want to
do to them
and one of the things you want to do to
them especially as you see
soon i will be constructing equivalence
relations to talk about by simulation is
i want to quotient my space
with an equivalence relation and polish
spaces are not so nice
so partly
as i said this whole thing took a long
time before we got off the ground
and one of the things that stymied me
was i couldn't prove that if i took a
polish space and took a quotient of it
that i would get a polish space and the
reason i couldn't prove it is because
it's false
and mike mislove pointed this out to me
so you take for example
the positive quadrant of the plane and
rather than showing you an equivalence
relation i'll show you
equivalence classes so you take the
hyperbolas
and you try to define a metric on these
hyperbolas you see they all scrunch
together
it won't in fact be a metric space or
metrisable
so we needed something else
so i didn't know i had never heard of
analytic spaces at this point
and i was staying at a at the university
at orhus
which has a which is a wonderful place
kusha and i spent a year
there together once and um so i was
visiting again
one year and there's a little flat on
the top floor of the computer science
building where you can stay
and the key to that uh apartment also
opens the library
and also opens everyone else's office so
that is one of the
charming socialist aspects of life in
denmark so everyone's key opened
everyone's office
and also my apartment so
so one night i was sleepless being jet
lagged and i went down to the library
and i started browsing through
uh various books some years before that
i remember professor scott told me i
should look at descriptive set theory
because it will bound to be playing an
important role in what i was doing and
of course uh it didn't immediately i
didn't well i didn't do this
immediately but i i tried i looked at a
few descriptive set theory books but i
couldn't see the connection right off
the bat
but then miraculously as i was browsing
randomly in the library i
found some lemmas about analytic spaces
which of course is kind of one of the
starting points of descriptive set
theory
and it turned out to be uh the key that
unlocked some things
so analytic sets do not form a sigma
algebra
but they are in the completion of the
borel algebra under any probability
measure so there's what are called
universally measurable
and you can do lots of nice things with
them
importantly disintegrations namely
regular conditional probabilities can be
defined on these analytic spaces
not just on polish spaces and here are
the two amazing facts that
completely destroyed my night's sleep
supposing i have an analytic space and
an equivalence relation
such that there is a countable family of
real valued measurable functions
from the set
oh my god why did i call this s from a
to r
such that two points are equivalent if
and only if
all the functions agree on them okay
so an equivalence relation might or
might not have this property
if i have such this property it's called
as smooth equivalence relation
so if i take an analytic space and a
smooth equivalence relation and i
quotient it
by this and by quotient it i mean set
theoretically the obvious thing i take
the equivalence classes
but i look for the finest sigma algebra
making the canonical surjection
measurable
then that thing is also analytic
okay so this is one somewhat amazing
fact
maybe not so amazing because analytic
spaces have these strong stability
properties as we've already seen
but it gave me hope because this was
what i had been trying to do i said ah
maybe we should be doing analytic spaces
now here's the thing that i've never
dreamed of
if you take an analytic space
and with its borel algebra sigma and
suppose you have a sub sigma algebra of
it
okay subsequent algebra of it which
separates points so that means if i have
any two distinct points i
promise you i can find disjoint
measurable sets
in my subsigma algebra that contain
these two points
okay so that's what it means to separate
points and for so that means it's not
too fine
i've not made it so crude that it can't
even tell the distinction between points
but it's not too huge that means it's
countably generated
then this subsequent algebra is actually
the whole thing
okay so this is called the unique
structure theorem there is no room
to put a countably generated sigma
algebra
inside that's a strict sub-sigma algebra
unless you want to make it so crude that
it doesn't even distinguish points
okay why why is this
relevant you will see presently okay so
keep these facts about analytic spaces
in mind and we will
now go back to try and prove the main
theorem
okay so here's the idea
basically we want to show that
the equivalence relation s and s prime
satisfy the same formulas of the logic
that's an equivalence relation of course
we want to show that that is a
bisimulation relation that'll of course
prove
that that logic characterizes by
simulation because it will tell you if
two things
are logically equivalent they are in
fact quite similar
now we can easily show that if i take
sets
of this form so this brackets i'm
assuming
everybody implicitly understands it
this is simply the set of states
satisfying
the formula
so if i look only at sets that are the
denotations of formulas
then it's easy to show that
right because if that weren't true then
i could write down a formula on which
they disagree
because there would be some difference
in the transition probabilities and i'd
put a diamond
aq in front of my phi and i'd get
formulas on which they disagree
okay but of course these are far from
being
all the sets
now
essentially we use the lambda pi theorem
to show that we can get a well-defined
measure on the sigma algebra generated
by such
sets such that the above equality holds
so of course
these sets don't form a sigma algebra
but they generate one
and then we use the special properties
of analytic spaces to show that this
actually is everything we want
and that's the outline of the proof
okay so how how do we proceed in detail
so we have to um the first thing we're
going to do
is we're going to take our original
space and quotient it
by this logical equivalence okay so
we've got
an lmp so defined on an analytic space
we have the equivalence relation which
says that they obey exactly the same
formulas of our modal logic
two states are logically equivalent if
they obey exactly the same formulas
and now i claim that's a smooth
equivalence relation
why because the indicator functions of
the definable sets
are exactly the things that characterize
that equivalence relation okay so
recall this notation so this means the
set of states that satisfy the formula
phi
this indicator function says if you're
in that set i'll give you one
otherwise i'll give you zero and two
things
agree on all formulas precisely when all
these functions agree so these are just
the characteristic functions
of the sets defined by the formulas
so here we have a countable family of
measurable functions how do i know
they're measurable because these sets
are measurable
such that two states are equivalent
if and only if the functions agree on
all of s
so there we have it a smooth equivalence
relation
one of the reasons why i restricted the
logic to have
only rational numbers in the logic the
systems
of course can have arbitrary real
numbers but not the logic
so i get a smooth equivalence relation i
can quotient it and i know that the
quotient space is analytic
and i know that the projection map is
measurable
that's almost almost everything i need
in fact
okay so so far i know that this quotient
space with its quotient sigma algebra
is uh uh is an analytic space i now want
to endow it
with
with a transition probability function
okay so there
is a kind of um functional analog of
this notion of bisimulation called a
zigzag
which is another term we picked up from
modal logic
if i have two of these systems i'm
suppressing the sigma algebra
and a zigzag is a function such that
yeah oops too many parents
okay so basically this is saying
this f preserves transition
probabilities
all right so i'd like to say i'd like to
be able to put
a transition probability structure on
top of this space in such a way that the
projection map
the canonical surjection from the set
onto its quotient is in fact not just
uh measurable but actually preserving
the transition probability structure
so called zigzag all right so
that's easy i'll just define this to say
if you give me a point t down here in q
and a measurable set there i will look
at the inverse image which i know is
measurable upstairs
because q is measurable and i look at s
where s is some chosen point
in the inverse image of the
so we need to check that this thing is
well defined because i could have picked
any old thing i want how do i know
that the transition probabilities i get
down there
are actually well defined in this way so
the first thing to note
is this uh curious fact that
q inverse of q of the denotation of a
formula phi is in fact exactly the
denotation of phi
okay and here is in font too small for
you to read
a demonstration of that fact it's a
totally elementary thing
that's why i don't want you to read it
but if you're truly suspicious you can
check it out anyway the point is
normally the form forward image of a set
is absolutely not measurable
and that's not the definition of a
measurable function right it's inverse
images of measurable sets are measurable
but this time
it so happens that the forward images of
these sets
are in fact measurable sets downstairs
precisely because of that
okay so thus these sets are measurable
okay so i can look at the sigma algebra
generated by these sets
so and i i'll call this lambda let's say
so it's a sub sigma algebra of omega
now this is countably generated
and it clearly separates points right
because if you land on on different
points then
there's some formula in which you
disagree so by the unique structure
theorem it is all of omega so this
is the power of this theorem you start
thinking oh i can only do this on the
definable sets and that surely must be
far too few of them but this theorem
tells you don't worry
just do it on what you know how to do
and i will take care of it for you
so the unique structure theorem really
helps us there
because now we know that this fact
doesn't just generate some subsequent
algebra it generates all of it
okay it's still
so rho is defined on all the sets
i still don't know that is well defined
however because i could have picked
different points in the inverse image of
of my point t and how do i know they
they match up
so you remember on tuesday i told you
why i love pi systems it's because
if you have a pi system generating a
sigma algebra
and you have two measures that you know
are measures
and you find out that they agree on the
pi system they agree on the whole
generated sigma algebra
now this collection of sets the
generating sets that come out of the
logic
form a pi system for the simple reason
that they contain conjunction
that's why conjunction is in the logic
so everything that's in the logic has to
be there more or less
okay so if we show that the two measures
that you get by choosing different
points actually agree on this
these sets they will agree on all of
omega okay so supposing i have
q of s and q of s prime both of them
going down to t
then it so happens that t of s phi
has to be equal to t of s prime phi and
this is a simple interpolation argument
right because if these things are
different then they will disagree on
some formula i can cons
i will always find some rational number
between those two transition
probabilities
i can use that to annotate my diamond
and
as they say in australia bob's your
uncle never understood what that meant
but there it is
okay now
look at this so i now want to
show that the transition probabilities i
get uh
upstairs have to be the same so if i
look at
t of s q inverse q five
these must match up because these things
are in fact those i proved that
okay so uh
that is what tells you that rho is well
defined
all right and we have the zigzag
property that we were looking for
and we now know that this row is
actually defined everywhere not just on
the definable sets
so that's it we just have to complete
the argument
by looking at what happens to these
equivalents closed subsets of s that
means unions of equivalence classes
okay so let x be any such set and you
look at
q inverse q x so that's equal to x and
we know that q
x itself is an element of omega
so if we compare these transition
probabilities
t a s x this is just a simple inequality
a simple
equality i proved before this is the
zigzag property that gets gets me down
there
well q of s and q of s prime are the
same thing
they're logically equivalent so they go
to the same equivalence class so then i
go back
up and i get that and therefore this is
just
x so i get the equality that i want okay
so for
any equivalence closed sets
bingo the transition probabilities match
up
okay so this is a bit like you know when
those tourists climb up mount everest
and they have sherpa guides kind of drag
them up there so
perhaps you feel a bit like that that
some black magic happened
and indeed it does look a bit like black
magic because suddenly
instead of what you might have thought
would be some combinatorial argument
about the structure of the transition
trees got replaced by
some measure theory arguments
i think a more combinatorial argument
can be given certainly not by me but
bartek clint has given
a cleaned up proof of this maybe one day
we can persuade him to give a
formal or informal talk about it but
still uses some measure theory
ingredients at least the lambda pi
theorem
okay so that's by simulation what about
simulation
before when you went to the logic we had
not put any yes
right right but you saw that you can
somehow simulate the case
right no i never said that okay
you bypass the i yeah can bypass it is
very different from simulating it
so this logic is the maximum in some
sense you can't put modern features in
the logs you can still get the same
result or you could
you can't put fewer features it's the
minimal
you can't take any features out of it
and still get the same result you
definitely need conjunction
you definitely need that modal operator
otherwise you'll not be able to say
anything about transitions and that's
all you've got
oh so on the other side you can put lots
of stuff
things that preserve by yes so very very
rich logics preserved by simulation
the point is to characterize it all you
need is this extremely simple logic
so that that should be yeah um so your
setup
presumably generalizes standard
probabilistic by simulation on finite
state
uh transition systems right yeah so
um suppose you and we know how to
compute probabilistic isolation on
finance and transition systems easily
suppose i do that and i find two states
are not
bisimilar uh how can i
efficiently generate a formula in your
logic
how so what what
how big would that be so is it is it is
it a small thing is it just
sort of something that so i i i know i
should be giving you a really
quantitative answer and
i can't remember but it is it is
reasonable yeah
so so jose's thesis has an algorithm for
generating the formula
okay yeah so it's a good question and uh
i should know this but i still don't
remember but it's not it's not hard
it's neither difficult the algorithm nor
is the formula generated
big okay in a sense what this is saying
is that you can't simulate negations
no no it depends distinguishes you can
write it up with negations probably
well you can probably write it with
negations the one that distinguishes
but by the standard argument or
something
but but he's saying he doesn't have
negation yeah but then there is an
algorithm to transform it into a
monotony one so
so they have an algorithm that
so our algorithms that are not
similar or by similar but you don't have
the formula that distinguishes it yeah
it generates the formula
and it generates the formula in this
logic no doubt
if you made richer logics you would get
much more compact formulas absolutely
i was talking about the positive
formulas yes yes yes
so it you can generate an algorithm for
it
by the way you also i thought you were
going to ask something else
which was that so as i said um
at the time that we did this proof for
the continuous case the people who had
done the discrete things still had
negative stuff so this was also it
after the fact a proof that for the
discrete world you didn't need it either
and i still don't know a pure
combinatorial proof
of logical characterization for discrete
systems that doesn't go through some
amount of measure theory
so that's interesting you have one
oh awesome next week i have another
question yes
this proof really crucially depends on
the set of formulas being countable yes
which means that we rely on the set of
labels
being counted yes so the question is you
know how do you sleep at night because
it shouldn't matter because both in
logic and
by simulation we universally quantify
over the set of labels and sort of it's
really independent what happens between
different labels
we should we should be fine with
uncountably many labels there's
something wrong here
morally
it's true that if i was trying to
describe systems like steering a car
i would like to have an uncountably many
labels i mean
right because there's a continuous
continuum of possible
ways of of taking actions namely
for example if you think about label
transition systems
then for the logic with binary
conjunction
to characterize by simulation you need
finite branching
but the set of labels can be anything
you don't need
any assumption on that but here suddenly
you you impose this assumption which is
very strange
looks crude
let's uh solve it during the semester
it's a good point i mean i've often
responded to this by saying
well i can make countable approximations
to use label spaces
and and you know prove things there but
uh but you're right maybe we should try
to do it for uncountable label spaces
certainly my friends in robotics
always say what about uncountable labels
because those are the people who are
indeed steering things
using continuous parameter spaces to
guide their robot
of course some people drive as if they
were discrete but
mostly we would like continuous label
spaces i totally agree
just so i understood so what needs to be
countable
the the number of distinct formulas yes
but i thought the formulas are have also
parameters which are probabilities in
them
okay so you for that reason alone you
have to restrict them to be rationals
i see rationals are good enough because
fortunately between any two rails
there's a rational
and so that is what allowed me to
construct distinguishing formulas even
though
the transition systems themselves were
not restricted in that way
yeah okay so let's talk about
uh simulation so i won't prove anything
here
so simulation is just like by simulation
you see that i've replaced
this what had been an equality before by
an inequality
so basically it says that s prime can do
everything
s can do with better probability
and now you can ask well is there a
logical characterization
for simulation now notice if the logic
had negation you would have no hope of
this right
so it's important that the logic was
purely positive so it was even a viable
question
of course it doesn't mean that the
answer is yes it just means
it is a question that can be asked
so
uh you can show this that if
s simulates s prime then s
will satisfy all the formulas that s
prime satisfies
possibly more okay so that that's nice
but what about the converse so it turns
out so i was sure that this was true but
jose came up with a counter example
so here is her counter example and maybe
how much time have i got yes i think
it's worth drawing this
so that when i flip to the next slide
you will still see this
here is s it has two
transitions so when i don't put a label
it means the label is a
and when i don't put a number it means
the number is one so this is just to
prevent it from being too cluttered
here is t maybe i'll put t on this side
so t has four things coming out
each with equal probability
and then i'm not going to name all the
states
this one is a dead state
okay so all the transitions coming out
of srt are labeled with a
so this is four-way branching with
uniform probabilities
and this state is called t1 i didn't
bother to name the dead states or these
ones
now you can give an example of a formula
that is satisfied by t
but not by s
okay because t has the possibility of
going somewhere
and then having both a and b available
to it that doesn't happen there
okay if you wind up here you can only do
a if you wind up here you can only do b
so clearly these are not quite similar
however it's not true that t
simulates s because there's a formula
with this junction that's satisfied by s
but not by t so this junction if you
recall was not in my logic before
but if i consider logics with this
junction
then this particular formula is
satisfied by s
but not by t because this says with
probability
greater than three quarters i can either
do an a
or a b and that's exactly this is with
probability one
i can wind up somewhere where either i
can do an a or i can do a b
whereas here it's exactly three quarters
remember my annotations were it had to
be strictly greater than
all right so this leads you to suspect
in fact
even though uh it looks as if t should
be able to simulate s it actually can't
so how do you give a logical
characterization of
simulation it turns out that you have to
add this junction
finitary disjunction to the logic still
of course everything is positive
and this proof turned out to be quite a
bit harder but maybe
bartek will come up with a simple
version in a few weeks
but with this logic we were able to
prove that
s1 simulates s2 if and only if for every
formula of our logic with this junction
s1 satisfies 5 implies s2 satisfies phi
and the only proof that we know uses
domain theory
so one can actually organize lmps into a
domain and
look at samsung bramsky's work on
logical characterization
of simulation sorry on domain theory in
logical form
and apply it and and then ultimately we
were able to prove this result
and go back to sleep samson without
pointing space isn't the weather i'm
confused
before you had all these machinery from
the screen you said
no we still have that machinery and
domain theory
that's really fun yes
okay so as i remarked before other
logics can also characterize by
simulation
for example if we add negation it's
still fine
uh and by the way several people have
suggested
that somehow i'm using arithmetic on the
probabilities to
simulate negation it's absolutely not
true because if i had a logic with
finitely many actions
super crude bartek finitely many actions
and i had negation in my logic i could
write down a formula that's only obeyed
by the dead process
which basically says no i can't do an a
no i can't do a b no i can't do a c
and nothing in my logic allows me to
write down a single formula that's only
satisfied by the dead process this shows
that not that i'm somehow able to
simulate
negation it's just that i'm able to
avoid it
and of course much richer logics are
also invariant under by simulation so
in particular fixed point logics and all
kinds of things that you would actually
want in an expressive
logic for reasoning about probabilities
for
reasoning about probabilistic systems
so let me wrap up strong probabilistic
by simulation is characterized by a very
simple modal logic with no negative
constructs
there is indeed also a logical
characterization of simulation
there is a metric on lmps which is based
on this logic
so just to anticipate some of the same
propaganda that i will be spouting
tomorrow
okay so it's fine to have a theorem like
this but is it really sensible to
work with this kind of concept when
you're dealing with probabilistic
systems
the definition of by simulation said
probabilities had to match
exactly so we're
requiring exact real arithmetic somehow
our exact comparison of of real numbers
and it really doesn't make sense would
one would if one had two by similar
systems
and then you perturb the probabilities
just a little bit suddenly you would say
ah
they're not quite similar anymore this
is too drastic
a response rather one should have some
kind of metrical notion that measures
closeness so that one can gracefully say
you know the things are getting less and
less similar
and there's some numerical measure of
how far apart they are
so this metric is what i will be talking
about tomorrow a metric that measures
closeness of behavior
rather than exactly quality but
that metric is based on ideas that come
out of this logic
there are things that i didn't really
understand why the proof required so
many subtle properties of analytic
spaces
it's true that uh bartek has gotten rid
of many of them
but i think it's still true that
it's not purely combinatorial it's it's
kind of a measured theoretic argument
it turns out though there is another
definition of by simulation
you see the thing that we did here was
focus on points
and on points being by similar and maybe
one shouldn't even be talking about
points
one should be talking rather about
events so there was another definition
of by simulation we gave much later
called event by simulation which is much
more adapted
to the idea of working with measurable
sets rather than these very sharp pointy
things
it turns out that the proof of logical
characterization is easy and works for
arbitrary measurable spaces not just
analytic ones
but then of course if you go back to the
people who like
the traditional notion of by simulation
and they ask well when do they coincide
with the coincide on analytic spaces and
then
so you can say well instead of saying
you have a hard proof of the logical
characterization of bisimulation
you can say we have a hard proof that
these two different notions
are the same
i don't have any slide 30 out of 29
today so
i will end there thanks
so before people run away i should
remind you we're supposed to
be supposed to be lined up for a
photograph of the boot camp right after
this
but any quick questions before we go for
the photo
okay good